across America leftist many of whom
certainly did not vote for Hillary
Clinton took to the streets to protest
against Donald Trump's election in LA
they tagged police cars with the
graffiti f Trump in New York Lady Gaga
led protests from death which is just
awesome in Philadelphia unhinged
leftists tagged a window with swastikas
and the slogan is Sieg Heil 2016
protests also broke out in Chicago and
Boston and other major cities the media
naturally played down violence and
arrests in Chicago for example five
people were arrested the Chicago Tribune
headline said five arrested after
largely peaceful Trump protests downtown
I don't remember that headline about the
tea party ten arrested after a largely
peaceful Tea Party event Republicans he
parties who were entirely peaceful never
received this kind of treatment but
these protests raised a couple of
questions first why when Barack Obama
won re-election in 2012 conservatives
were deeply depressed we didn't hold
mass protests elections our elections we
processed it Obamacare we protested tarp
we protested executive amnesty we did
not protest the election itself and
president-select Trump whom by the way I
oppose throughout the primaries and
didn't vote for during the general and I
think he's a bad person but he hasn't
done anything yet I think he's an
objectionable again I don't need a good
person but his victory doesn't change
that but as I wrote yesterday I hope he
proves me wrong about that and I'm gonna
give him a chance to prove me wrong
about all of that but no matter what you
think about Trump as a person he hasn't
done anything yet as president he's not
president yet he's president-elect so
what are they protesting other than
reality do they think that Donald Trump
is sitting there going they're
protesting I guess it won't be President
now or is he actually just gonna bathe
in their salty bitter tears second what
comes after this if the Democrats are
protesting Trump before he even does
anything what can we expect when he
actually begins acting as president well
the left to begin engaging in mass
violence beyond mere protest the what's
histrionic rioting helps generate
exactly the sort of anger that led to a
president Truong their continued rioting
won't get him reelected Trump won
because Americans didn't show up for
Hillary not because of some enormous
surge for Trump who actually may end up
winning fewer popular votes than Mitt
Romney but it certainly will not
convince Americans to join the idiotic
ridiculous and stupid anti Trump crowd
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
oh okay so here we are so much to get to
today and some so much hilarity I mean I
a promise hilarity and an hilarity shall
be delivered I mean we were promised a
circus the clowns are all here it's it's
it's just fantastic all the way across
the board
I promise we'll get through all of it
first we have to say hello to our
friends over at Birch gold so if in
these uncertain times you are worried
about the economy I think honestly I'm a
little less worried about the economy
now that I was before but I'm more
worried about the Fed raising the
interest rates which would which would
send real estate in the stock market
plummeting if you're worried about those
sorts of things you need to hedge your
bets with birchgold.com birchgold.com /
Ben and you you go there you get a free
you get a freak it's like 16-page get
about investing in precious metals
they've been a plus rating from the
Better Business Bureau they can help you
shift your IRA or 401k into precious
metals without tax consequences again
these are the folks I would trust fire
investing in precious metals and I do
its birchgold.com / Ben okay so I have
to say that everything is just
hysterically funny
everything has now and we've entered the
realm of the absurd and we are and we
are beyond anything remotely resembling
reality this alternative reality that we
entered into about 15 months ago now is
gonna continue for four years and what's
bizarre about this alternative reality
is that people like me who think that
Donald Trump is is basically a bad
person we're rooting eagerly for him to
do some pretty good things and I think
he's going to do some some pretty good
things particularly early in his
presidency but we'll get to that in a
minute first we have to get to the story
of the day it's just oh my god
Donald Trump goes to the White House
presidents elect Trump president elect
Donald Trump go I have to meet the
outgoing President Barack Obama and it
is just glorious it is no justice can be
done through weird channels this is true
like I don't think that Donald Trump has
met justice for all of the all of the
terrible things he did during the
primaries in the general but he's
delivering justice like Wyatt Earp in
Tombstone to to to President Obama
imagine brocco bomb and your image of
yourself is you're this great state's
person you are a wonderful thinker
you're a deep man
you are transformative president the
first black president in American
history you're a man who asks with the
dignity of Martin Luther King and the
and the forethought of Gandhi you are
just God's gift to the world and your
successor who's going to wipe out all of
the things that you did all of them is a
reality TV show star you consider to be
an illiterate orangutan and that's what
just happened at the way look at this
look at this this is everything this
this picture is everything oh it's
phenomenal okay so for those who are
gonna be listening to this on the
podcast later and can't actually see
this and can't actually see this picture
oh my god so it's Donald Trump
giving the Trump finger to the press
Trump giving the Trump finger to the
press the same finger that he used to
fire Omarosa he's giving to the press
right now sitting next to Barack Obama
who looks like he had a rod rim straight
up his ass and he's just and Obama is
sitting start straight in his chair and
gazing off into the distance like a
Vietnam War vet who saw all of his
buddies get blown away and then behind
them is a bust of Abraham Lincoln
frowning every I'm Lincoln mourning for
his country ever ahem Lincoln so it
turns out came back to life just to
shoot himself in the back of the head
because this is this is what oh my god
this is what America has become it's
just it's phenomenal come on ok this is
this is Barack Obama's worst nightmare
come to life this is all the nightmares
rolled into one it is all of the
nightmares and they are all wonderfully
coming true for Barack Obama and here's
another picture oh my god you see the
Statue of Liberty that picture of the
Stata painting the Statue of Liberty in
the background assert or she goes yeah
you see Barack Obama's sitting there
this guy who thinks that he is the god
king of the United States the man who is
supposed to be the great leader who
restored America to dignity and Wonder
and there's Barack Obama leaning into
camera looking like he wants to die and
Donald Trump sitting there like give me
a birth certificate right now or Obama
cares on the table it's just every bit
of Justice that Obama deserve it's all
the things it's all of them I can't
stand Donald Trump as you know on a
personal level I think that he's gonna
do some good things as president or at
least I hope you will and I'm willing to
I'm willing to give him time to change
as a man
but the fact that he is who he is is
what makes this wonderful if this had
just been Marco Rubio accepting from
Barack Obama justice has not been done
the fact that it is Donald Trump
accepting from Barack Obama is what
makes this so wonderful because it is
Donald Trump a man who is a reality TV
show clown man him accepting from a guy
who considers himself to be the most
dignified human ever to walk the earth
and look at this handshake from treating
it like like he's about to like he's
about to take the presidency of the
United States and Obama looking at him
like I can't believe that this is in the
mirror and that's really what this is
about because Obama's vision of himself
this is the truth about Obama and Trump
Trump is just Obama without some of the
trappings not with regard to policy with
regard to personality and the way I say
this is that they're both narcissists
obviously but beyond that the reality TV
show of star nature of Donald Trump it
is I mean this whole campaign was a
reality TV show that reality TV show
stuff the fact of reality TV show star
is now the president-elect of the United
States that is a direct reflection of
the fact that Barack Obama was a
celebrity reality TV show star for eight
years that's what this is I mean for
example here is Barack Obama well just
selfie stick Barack here this is the
president of the United States right
this is and there are those of us who
said at the time this is undignified
this is not what the presidency is for
you got Barack Obama winking himself in
the selfie stick the upper rock Obama
hanging out in Hollywood every five
minutes I mean shuts down traffic in LA
where we are every week he's out here
doing Jimmy Kimmel
he got Barack Obama doing this routine
where he where he is
doing interviews with glozell right the
lady who the lady who bathes and Froot
Loops right he is a reality TV show star
he is a celebrity it's why his
popularity ratings are high and it's why
he and it for the same reason his
popularity ratings are high but his
policies mean nothing that's how you get
Donald Trump because you go from reality
TV show start a reality TV show star
Obama doesn't see himself that way but
that's who he is and you can see it so
you know we'll skip ahead a little bit
but you guys can grab clip 22 so this is
it so this is Barack Obama reading mean
tweets on Jimmy Kimmel and this again
this is everything this is you want to
know how Donald Trump got to be
President of the United States it's all
right here in the small clip from Jimmy
Kimmel of Barack Obama President Obama
will go down as perhaps the worst
president in the history of the United
States exclamation point at real Donald
Trump at real Donald Trump at least I
will go down as president that's justice
right there that is justice coming in
the form of Donald's from to Barack
Obama and justice is indeed sweet it may
you know again do I think it's good for
the country that we now have reality TV
show start running it I'll wait till a
seat until I see his policies do I think
that he's somebody who would strike me
as qualified for the office no as I said
to my wife you've studied for years and
years and years to be a doctor if
somebody made the head of your Hospital
a guy who had once played operation then
you'd have a right to be then you'd have
a right to be slightly worried about it
or slightly concerned about it maybe
he'll do some good stuff but but but by
the same token when it comes to just
justice for Barack Obama just justice
for Barack Obama
karma it is spectacular spectacular and
it wasn't just by the way that tweet
again the this week there he's on Kimmel
he reads it Trump tweet saying he'll
never be and then he says you'll never
be president and drops it on Kimmel as a
reality star you're only on Kimmel if
you're a reality star right he is a
reality star and he's a replaced by a
reality star and you can see all of his
visions of himself shattering in those
pictures with Donald Trump and in its
just that rhyming it did Seth Meyers
taunting Donald Trump about Barack Obama
and this is I think clip 23 it's just
here's who Seth Meyers is at the White
House Correspondents Dinner in 2011 same
dealer Donald Trump has been saying that
he will run for president as a
Republican which is surprising since I
just assumed he was running as a joke
and there's term sitting there right it
wasn't a joke
it wasn't a joke definite Trump often
appears on Fox which is ironic because
the Fox often appears on Donald Trump's
head
it here at the Washington Post table
with Trump and you can't finish your
entree don't worry the Fox will eat it
Gary Busey said recently that Donald
Trump would make a great president of
course he said the same thing about an
old rusty birdcage he found
Donald Trump owns the Miss USA pageant
which is great for Republicans because
it will streamline their search for a
vice president
now I know that he's taken some flak
lately but no one is happier no one is
prouder to put this birth certificate
matter to rest than the Donald and
that's because he can finally get back
to focusing on the issues that matter
like did we fake the moon landing what
really happened in Roswell and where are
Biggie and Tupac
all kidding aside obviously we all know
about your credentials and breadth of
experience for example no seriously just
recently in an episode of Celebrity
Apprentice at the steakhouse the men's
cooking team did not impress the judges
from Omaha Steaks
and there was a lot of blame to go
around but you mr. Trump recognized that
the real problem was a lack of
leadership and so ultimately you didn't
blame little Jon or meatloaf you fired
Gary Busey and these are the kind of
decisions that would keep me up at night
okay
there's Barack Obama being a reality TV
show star at the White House
Correspondents Dinner making fun of
Donald Trump doing it on camera making
fun of Donald Trump all of this is why
Donald Trump is where Donald Trump is
the only way that you get to this level
with the American presidency is because
we've been there before and we were
there before in the form of a guy who
thinks of himself as a dignified man who
can sneer at Donald Trump so I just had
to I just had to point out the absolute
hilarity and wonder of it because it
truly is amazing and wonderful we have
to break for just a second say hello to
our friends over at hint water so this
water is delicious hint water it's it's
it's just water it's not sugar they
don't put artificial flavoring in there
it's all natural
but you taste just a smidgen of flavor
of these various flavors it's really
really good stuff my daughter loves it I
love it my wife loves it it's started by
a gal named carat gold and she was she
was overweight and she's been drinking
diet soda and she decided that she
wanted to actually create a better
tasting water because water tasted
boring and it does taste boring and and
so she created hints it's really good
stuff right now you can get a single
variety pack shipped to your door for 15
bucks at drink hint com slash been drink
hints.com slash been and normally it's
24 bucks you get it for 15 if you use
the slash been and that's pineapple
watermelon Crisp Apple and Blackberry
it's drink hint com slash bend the stuff
is really really really good
I enjoy people in the office didn't even
know they were an advertiser and they're
walking around drinking these bottles it
really is first-rate okay so that's on
the hilarious side on the hilarious side
there is Donald Trump visiting the White
House and demonstrating in full karmic
effect what Barack Obama is to the world
and it's just glorious on the other
comedic side they're a bunch of
anti-trump protesters who've been going
around making jerks of themselves and
and they look like fools and it does
demonstrate what Trump is up against in
the sense that the left has already pre
decided that he's going to be awful and
they're going to oppose anything he does
and that's not a shock but I'm old
enough to remember when Rush Limbaugh
said that he hoped Barack Obama would
fail and that his agenda would fail and
the left pot that was unpatriotic and
awful I guess we're back to the era of
dissent being patriotic again here's a
video of some protesters yesterday
family my family okay and then she
eventually said people you know she says
people are gonna have to die on both
sides yeah lady I don't see you doing
the dying and and all these people who
say they're gonna participate in violent
protests yeah there was a lot of talk
that Donald Trump supporters would be
violent all the people who voted for
Donald Trump were people who were very
ticked at Barack Obama none of them
rioted after Barack Obama won in 2012
but Democrats get to get away with
anything UCSD University of California
San Diego you're seeing some of the same
sort of stuff here's some of the
students protesting that things last
night think is going to accomplish
nothing it's not going to accomplish
anything other than to toxify Trump
before he even is able to do a single
thing in office which is really quite
despicable now you're free you're free
to do all this stuff let's your
prerogative but the idea that Donald
Trump is is going to suddenly resign his
office because a bunch of whiny college
students have decided they don't want to
accept the results of a duly enacted
election that's that's utter foolishness
and and these things continue here's
another anti-trump protesters from
Mediaite
I'm here because my ancestors came to
the
country a hundred years ago and they
knew people who are burned in factory
fires and people like Donald Trump would
have let them die and not allow the
factory you safety legislation to take
place all of the people who are yelling
about Trump and see how many of them who
are protesting the elections him I need
them actually voted I guarantee you a
bunch of these people didn't vote a
bunch of these people didn't vote and
now they're now they're ticked off
because they don't like the results of
the election it's getting uglier than
that this is a video of apparently the
reportedly a Trump voter being dragged
from his car and beaten this this has
been making the rounds as well this is a
you can see these are a couple of black
youths beating a white guy up after
pulling him from his car and he must
have had a Trump bumper sticker and
that's how they know something along
those lines
and they're punching him and beating him
if that's the direction this country is
gonna go because of front first of all I
don't think that Donald Trump is going
to is going to stand for that and that's
one of the reasons Donald Trump was
elected and that's a very good thing
nobody should stand for this kind of
crap this sort of stuff has to stop and
if the left continues to do this the
backlash that the Left saw in 2012 is
gonna be a hell of a lot larger in 2016
okay well we have to break for Facebook
and YouTube unfortunately if you want to
watch the rest live go over to Daley
wire.com Daley wire com $8 a month we'll
get you your subscription it means that
you can also view our website without
ads it means that that you can view my
show live view part of the mailbag with
the mailbag today which is excited means
that you can get Andrew Klavan show live
as well and you can be part of his
mailbag and we have new goodies every
day for your an annual subscriber then
you go there right now you get a signed
copy of my new novel true allegiance and
you can you can be a part of the largest
conservative podcast in the United
States
you